hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast cost-benefit analysis of
expanding bone marrow derived using
Kamel stem cells using automated cell
expansion methods versus manual methods
dou T O'Rourke of leathers and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labyrinth comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by -
room o BCT - room obesity is a global
leader in blood component therapeutic a
phoresis and cellular technology
it is the only company with the unique
combination of a phoresis collections
manual and automated whole blood
processing and pathogen reduction
technologies to rule LD CTD believes in
the potential of blood to do even more
for patients than it does today
this belief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about Tarullo BCT please visit
www.cancer.gov
answer is welcome - and you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if you don't
have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome Tina
Russell and taa be Espino Russell is the
lead medical laboratory scientist of the
human cellular therapy laboratory and
assistant professor of laboratory
medicine and pathology at the Mayo
Clinic in Jacksonville Florida she has
held multiple positions at the Mayo
Clinic concentrating her work on mizenko
mole and kima
poetic planet stem-cell research and
other cellular and cell derived
therapies athena also holds elected
positions with the International Society
for cellular therapy and the American
Association of bio analysts I will now
turn the presentation over to Athena
Russell
the human cellular therapy laboratory at
Mayo Clinic down in Jacksonville Florida
I appreciate you all being here for this
webinar today and it's a pleasure to be
able to talk to you about analysis that
we did in our laboratory over the course
of about a year or so as we were
considering transitioning away from
using manual methods to expand bone
marrow Mozingo --ml stem cells towards a
more automated bioreactor type system we
really just wanted to know whether or
not it was going to be feasible for us
to do that given the resources that we
had to give you a little bit of
background about our laboratory so you
have some perspective our lab was
established about 25 years ago but
specifically to support the bone marrow
transplant program and to perform
traditional cellular therapy and
hematocrit extend cell processing
activities it wasn't until about four or
five years ago that we started to
develop protocols for investigational
cellular therapies with funding for the
return from the Center for regenerative
medicine at Mayo Clinic so we've been
developing all of our GMP production
protocols for MS ES and for some other
newer novel therapies that we're getting
into as well now though we only have
about 1200 square feet of space to share
with the bone marrow transplant team and
our regenerative medicine team and we
had some recent renovations where we
could take some of the laboratory and
turn it into clean room space for GMP
manufacturing however we're also not
only limited in space but we're also
limited in staff we only have about
three technologists working on all of
this work two of them on the bench and
one of them that handles all of the
quality and this is just a bird's-eye
view of what this 1200 square feet looks
like we have one cell processing area
dedicated to bone marrow transplant
product processing all of our storage
space is located here dry storage and
cold storage so all of the liquid
nitrogen storage for C minus 80 and
minus 20 storage is all located in this
within this footprint and then down
towards the bottom is all the newly
renovated space where there are two labs
that are certified as clean rooms
however because we are so limited we can
only use one of them for true
manufacturing and the other one we still
are needing to perform all of our
research and development work and these
are just some images from the labs you
can see kind of what I'm talking about
the picture on the left is of the larger
cleanroom space that we are meeting for
research and development activities so
it's a little bit of a larger space and
of course we have to flow hoods and to
standard size co2 incubators and this is
the smaller of the two rooms the
cleanroom space where we actually
perform our manufacturing processes this
is an older picture but at this time we
now have a small laminar flow hood in
the back and we have to quantum Sol
expansion systems over on the right-hand
side and then on the left here is our
San USL processing workstation which we
still have and it's really where we
began when we were developing all of our
manual cell expansion protocols so to
give you an idea of what our short-term
goals are with respect to manufacturing
again we're a small facility or an
academic manufacturing facility and so
we really only have the ability to
support phase one and phase two clinical
trials but what we really want to do is
to be able to support those clinical
trials that are initiated by
investigators and clinician
investigators here at the Mayo Clinic
campus in Florida so that we can promote
regenerative and cell therapy on our
campus so we want to be able to support
the main factoring needs of those here
who are interested in running and
developing iron.i NBS
for regenerative medicine and cell
therapy but again as I've mentioned a
few times now we have some pretty
obvious limitations and challenges
before us we have a very limited amount
of space that we have to work with and a
very limited staff that we have
to perform all of the development
activities and manufacturing activities
so I want to give you an idea of what
our manual manufacturing protocols were
looking like we use the cell processing
workstation as you saw in the images
earlier if you're not familiar the cell
processing workstation is a standalone
isolator type of system it is a class
100 environment on the inside once it's
been decontaminated it has its own
incorporated hydrogen peroxide
decontamination system it also has
everything else that you need to do cell
culture like a centrifuge and microscope
and an incubator the incubators are
modular so you can add additional
incubators if you need to but we don't
have the space for that so we just have
one modular incubator that's only 1.4
cubic feet on the inside contrast that
with a standard cell culture incubator
that has about 6 cubic feet of space on
the inside so we are working with a much
less space than what we're used to
having to handle all of our incubation
means we use multi layer flasks and with
all the options out there on the market
we are able to narrow it down to two
different types that we could use with
this modular incubator that those were
the millah pour high flasks which have
about a thousand square centimeters of
growth area and the corning hyper flask
which are tea 1720s this is what they
look like and for all of our
manufacturing methods we use alpha mem
and 5% platelet lysate we've gotten away
from SPS some time ago and this is how
we would do it we would start by
expanding the MSBs up to passage 1 to
create a master cell bank of vials of
MSC to do that we were able to scale up
to a maximum with 10 p1 thousands last
that's the maximum number of flat so we
can fit inside the modular incubator in
those 10 to 1,000 flasks we could
produce enough cells about 200 million
MSPs to freeze down about 100 vials of 2
million MFCs per vial for our masters
Elding
after that when we're ready to create a
batch of product we could pull vials
from the master cell bank and further
expand them up to passage 3 to create
batches of stem cell products that are
intended to be used for therapy to do
that we could scale up to a maximum of
10 t 17/20 flasks and at the end of all
this we could approximately create about
4 doses of product and each each dose
would have a hundred million MFCs in the
bag from start to finish which is from
the raw bone marrow aspirate all the way
to creating the very first batch of stem
cell product doses that manufacturing
campaign would take anywhere from 6 to 8
weeks to complete so there are some
pretty obvious limitations to doing a
display first of all you can only fit a
maximum of 10 of either type of
multi-layer flasks inside the incubator
so you're really limited in how many
cells you can produce the whole process
from start to finish is extremely
tedious very time-consuming and
labor-intensive you really absolutely
need at least two technologists to
perform these tasks efficiently I have
done it with one before during the
development phase and it just is not
feasible you consume a huge number or a
huge volume of culture medium doing it
this way each of the Corning hyper
flasks requires five hundred and
sixty-five milliliters of culture medium
to fill up the flask completely which
you have to do with those flasks and so
you can imagine towards the end when you
have 10 hyper flasks and every time you
do a medium change you need 6 liters
approximately 6 liters of media so you
can see how the costs and of medium and
player life say it can really add up
doing it this way and it's a relatively
long period of time from start to finish
and at the end you really do not get
that many doses of products so you're
putting in a lot and you're not really
getting a lot out of it so it didn't
take long for us to realize that we
needed to make some changes and do some
things
differently so we started thinking about
bioreactors we looked at a few different
systems there were three different
systems that we considered that were
small footprint single-use platforms one
of them of course is the to remove ECT
quantum cell expansion system one of the
platforms required the use of micro
carriers and the other two platforms the
cells grew out in a more traditional two
dimensional model layer type of manner
however one of those platforms we had to
exclude kind of early on for space
considerations because although it was
indeed a small footprint type of
platform it still required a little bit
more instrumentation to go along with
the whole thing than we had space for so
in the end we narrowed it down to two
systems the micro carrier system in the
quantum and we brought them both
in-house and tested them for expanding
bone marrow MSPs so we thoroughly
evaluated these two systems and
eventually we decided that we had to
rule out the micro carrier system a big
part of this was the amount of
involvement in the time that we were
going to need to translate our current
2-d system to a 3d system because really
if you've never worked at micro carriers
before they're just so different from
growing cells and flasks and there's a
lot of steps that need to be worked out
and developed along the way and we did a
lot of this during the evaluation phase
we did micro carrier screening assays
where we looked at a whole bunch of
different micro carriers and tried to
figure out which ones were going to work
best for our needs and for our cell type
there was also considerations regarding
the way that you have to prepare the
micro carrier some of them are
pre-sterilized some of them need to be
autoclave some of them many of them need
to be pre hydrated and all these things
you have to think about and in fact we
don't have easy access to an autoclave
we have to walk across the street to get
one and so obviously this wasn't really
an ideal situation for us regarding
monitoring of the culture you have to
think about that not knowing when the
cells are going to be confluent on the
barriers and also you need to keep a
certain cell to micro carrier ratio so
after a certain amount of time you have
to add more micro carriers and you have
to figure out how to how to know when to
do that so again just more steps that
need more development and then there's
the question of how to harvest the cells
from the micro carriers and once you do
how will you separate the micro carriers
from the cells you may need additional
equipment like a fluidized bed
centrifuge a lot of the techniques micro
carry separation techniques that were on
the market at the time when we did this
evaluation were designed for very large
scale applications and not really for
processing volumes in the Frye's liter
range which is where we were and then
after all this how can you do your
purity testing how can you be sure that
you have no micro carrier contamination
in the final product so again these are
all things that we could have worked out
over time but each one of these steps
needed to be developed and tested and it
would have taken a very considerable
amount of time for the two technologists
that we had doing this work so again we
eventually had to rule this this
platform out so we narrowed our options
down to the platform but we still really
weren't sure if this was going to be
right for us there were some obvious
benefits to using the quantum like the
small footprint with the eliminated
space that we have and also the relative
ease of translating our current
protocols to using the bioreactor there
was a reduction in the amount of time it
took for us to expand the cells and also
we were able to after doing a number of
pilot runs with two remotes help get to
where we could produce greater cell
yields in the bioreactor versus using
flasks and we're also able to keep the
cells at a lower passage for banking and
for production of MSC products but
probably the most valuable advantage for
our particular situation was the
addition of automation because it saved
us so much time with performing manual
tasks
there's also the possibility of
scalability with a quantum we have a
5,000 square foot GMP facility that is
being planned out right now hopefully
for this year or next year and so
hopefully when we get this new facility
and we have a little bit more space we
can add more Quantum's and once we're
familiar with the protocol we can just
do the same protocol with more Quantum's
and able and we'll be able to get more
cell yield so I'm trying to determine
whether or not this platform was going
to be right for us we had to ask the
question whether or not this automated
platform was going to measure up and
every sense to the current manual
protocol that we were using we looked at
a number of different parameters and we
did the analysis and we were able to put
out this poster that we presented the
world stem cell somewhat a couple years
ago if any was interested in looking at
this poster please feel free to email me
but I'm going to go over what we found
in the subsequent slides and again to
highlight what what our overarching
goals were first and foremost we needed
the ability to expand large quantities
of MSC s so that we could treat patients
and cell therapy and more general
medicine clinical trials and manufacture
those cells in compliance with GMP
standards and so with this analysis we
wanted to be able to compare the
automated versus manual method with
regard to cell yields cost time and
effort from the technologist and just
overall ease of performing the protocols
so what we did was we started with 25 25
to 30 milliliters of fresh bone marrow
aspirate and we performed the automated
method and the manual method basically
side by side we isolate and expanded
Romero MSC s using alpha mem and 5%
human play-doh lysate we created master
cell banks using the automated method
and a manual method and products using
both methods as well and then we just
quantified the difference as we looked
at again so yields we looked at the cost
of consumables and reagents needed to
perform these two different methods how
long it took to grow the cells how much
effort it required from the
technologists and how many technologists
we needed to do all the work
first looking at the automated method
you're able to dilute the bone marrow
and add it directly to the quantum
system you don't have to pre isolate the
mono nuclear cells as you normally do
you do have to pre coat the bioreactor
with fiber net and overnight or else the
cells will not adhere in order to
monitor the culture you look at glucose
consumption lactate generation and you
can also see control flasks at the same
seating densities just to give you a
visual of how complement the cells are
to help aid in your decision as to when
the cells are ready to be harvested you
can freeze down cells in two vials as
early as p0 but you get a lot more cells
at p1 and so we typically expand up to
p1 to create our master cell bank but
you will have additional vials at p0
that you can further expand to p1 to
create more cells to Bank and then of
course eventually up to create more
products the product that product bags
can be generated as early as passage 2
so you pull vials from passage 1 from
the master cell back and then just
expand them up one more passage to
create doses and the total area service
area for growth inside one bioreactor is
21,000 square centimeters for the manual
method we first isolated the modern
nuclear cells from the bone marrow using
cycle and then feed them directly to
t1000 flasks that were not coated at
actually 50 to 100 thousand cells per
centimeter squared we provide a fresh
media every 3 to 4 days passage to the
cells when they were about 85 to 90%
confluent and we froze down master cell
bank files at passage 1 we then pulled
vials from the master cell bank to
expand products but we couldn't do that
we couldn't actually freeze products
down until passage 3 because you don't
have that many cells in your vial for
passage 1 so you have to first expand
them to passage 2 and then you can
really scale up by passage 3 so a very
important thing to understand about how
we did this analysis because we didn't
do this based on using the cell
processing workstation knowing most
people don't have one most people are
going to be doing this
these manufacturing processes in a
cleanroom with standard cell closable
camps standard cell culture incubators
so we wanted to sort of normalize this
so that knowing that everybody has a
different kind of situation and not
everybody has the same number of
incubators in their laboratories we
wanted to just kind of normalize the
whole analysis down to the number of
cells you could produce using one
standard size six cubic foot cell
culture incubator and so in one standard
six cubic foot cell culture incubator we
were able to fit a maximum of 48 corning
hyper flasks p1 1720 into one of those
incubators for maximum capacity is about
82,000 square centimeters for cell
growth and this is what we came up with
I know this is a busy slide and I will
summarize it later but so you can see
how we did it we looked first at all the
reagents and consumables that we would
need to perform each process using each
method and for all the passages that we
need to perform using each method these
are the cost for the quantum and the
required passages associated with using
the quantum and also the cost for
expanding manually and these are all of
the parameters that we looked at we
looked at how much did it cost to run
each passage that we would need to run
exactly how much time it would take to
actually expand each passage how much
hands-on time it would take from the
technologists actually performing tasks
and how many technologists you would
need to perform the tasks and then of
course we looked at approximations of
how many cells you should be able to
expect from each of these passages doing
it one way or the other and how many
vials you can freeze down to create a
bank and how many doses you can expect
to manufacture and so finally we really
wanted to make sense of all of this data
and we wanted to kind of put it into
terms that would make sense to other
laboratories that were in the same
situation as a smaller laboratories I
want to
or a clinical trial at their institution
that have limited resources and so what
we did was we imagined a hypothetical
clinical trial that happening at our
institution where each subject is
supposed to receive one dose of 100
million ms CS and we wanted to ask
whether or not it would be possible for
us to manufacture the doses needed for
this clinical trial and how much would
it cost us to do it so looking at cost
what we found was that the manufacturer
of these hundred doses using the quantum
they would cost about a hundred thousand
dollars or a thousand dollars for those
or ten dollars per million MSP however
doing it a manual way using multi layer
flasks in a single cell culture
incubator it would cost about two
hundred thousand dollars to create the
same number of doses and so the costs
were about double and the majority of
that cost came really from the cell
culture media and cell culture
supplements because doing the manual
method using multi layer flasks that
require such large volumes of media it
just adds up the cost greatly and so the
majority of that increased cost really
came from the huge amounts of media that
you needed to do this procedure manually
versus using the automated quantum
system looking at this in terms of time
if you have just a single quantum it
takes it was to take about 13 passage to
runs to create the hundred doses that
you need to run this trial if you
perform all of those runs
back-to-back non-stop they would take
approximately twenty weeks or five
months to perform all of the
manufacturing activities needed to
generate those doses although it is nice
to have two technologists to perform
these tasks if it came down to it you
really only need one to do everything
because the tasks are so automated and
that one technologist only needs to
spend about thirty four total hours of
hands-on work to do everything required
in order to generate all of these doses
in contrast using the manual method you
would need to perform five runs and
within that and each run is defined as
pulling a vial from the master cell bank
and expanding out the passage to and
then a passage three to get your your
batch if you do all those batch runs
back-to-back it takes just a little
longer about twenty four weeks or six
months the original primary culture can
be done with one technologist but all of
the works that subsequent to that you
really need at least two technologists
to perform these tasks efficiently and
with those two technologists each one of
them would need to expend almost 200
hours of hands-on time doing all of the
manual tasks required to harvest all of
those 48 flats that you could fit into
one cell culture incubator if you have
additional incubator space you can have
more growth area and therefore more cell
yields but then again you'll you're
going to expend more medium and you're
going to need even more label labor to
handle the increase in flasks and
processing time so you really need more
people to handle that many flasks is the
takeaway points if you want to not
compromise the quality of your product
and the viability of the cells so in
summary we found that using the quantum
automated system instead of using the
manual multi layer flask based protocols
resulted in almost a 50% reduction in
the cost of reagents and consumables
needed to produce 100 doses of MSDS to
run this hypothetical clinical trial and
using the automated method resulted and
about a 17 percent decrease in the
amount of actual time needed to grow out
this many cells and using the automated
method resulted in an 82 percent
reduction
the number of hours needed to be
expended by the technologists in order
to do all this work and only require the
effort of one technologist versus two or
more technologists to do all the manual
tasks efficiently and we've concluded
that we are able to produce large
quantities of bone marrow mzingo mole
stem cells for clinical use using the
automated quantum system and that it
requires significantly less cost time
and effort on our part to do this over
the manual method using certain multi
layer flasks and that indeed is B method
the platform that we have gone with for
all of our future manufacturing needs
you
excellent presentation Athena thanks for
bringing that information to us we now
welcome Brent rice PhD from the cell
processing team at Tru mo BCT who is a
collaborator with Athena and now joins
us to answer your questions before we
get started with the Q&A sessions here's
a quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent David green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll get to as many
as we can our first question is did you
do a comparability study between sell
products grown in the flask and cells
grown in the bioreactor
yes indeed Athena did perform of
comparability study according to their
critical quality attributes so they're
indications of identity purity potency
and safety and they found that there was
no significant difference between the
two populations
I should also generally say that this is
something that is pursued by many and
probably most of our customers anybody
with a historical process of course has
their defined critical quality
attributes and then they test to ensure
that the cells produced by the quantum
system maintain these critical quality
and quality attributes H does your cost
include disposable cost of the quantum
yes the analysis that Athena provided
there are many line items one of which
is the the quantum disposables or
several of which are the quantum
disposables just as she also lists the
hyper flasks for the manual process and
one entity and handy asks could I get a
copy of the presentation and the poster
mentioned the the slides is currently
aren't available for distribution
however to my understanding this
presentation itself should be available
for the next six months as of today on
the labyrinth lab routes website okay
we have time for one last question if we
didn't get yours we will follow up the
view
email last question is have cells from
the quantum being used in patients and
fit require a GMT facility so yes you
know at this point the quantum system
has been used to produce many cells that
have been used in a variety of
treatments certainly early on more of
this use was in the context of
compassionate use or Hospital exemption
so for example treatment of GVHD as a
third line treatment or you know again a
last case resort for that that horrible
disease however thankfully you know over
the years more and more people have
submitted IMD's and more and more of
these IDs in the US are coming to
fruition in clinical studies so a couple
of examples would be for exempt or eval
disease and in glioma treatment and then
in the EU as well we're seeing a similar
pattern the most common are the most
significant clinical trial actually in
the world is in the EU where they've
treated well over 50 patients for heart
failure with adipose derived MSC's and
with regard to the question of facility
of course the most important thing to
acknowledge there is that that the
delineation of what type of facility is
necessary is a function purely of the
local regulatory authorities that being
said of course having a functionally
closed and automated system like the
quantum system allows you some more
flexibility and ability to make some
very good arguments for lowering the
classification of the that clean room
facility so it is not uncommon it is
quite common and even Envy the largest
clinical trial example that I that I
just mentioned in that case while a
flash-based process would have to be
pursued in a Class B facility in the EU
they had pursued the the use of the
quantum system in a class C facility
which has obvious benefits regarding
ease of use and and of course the costs
of the facility itself so yes
a more prominent clinical production and
a tendency towards using lower grade
green rooms as well good I would like to
once again thank Tina Russell and grant
rice for this presentation would also
like to thank our sponsor to room o BCT
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 12 2018 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you when it's
available on-demand and posted on
Latrice calm you are welcome to Ford
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time